mon premier article dans les cahiers
enfin j'ai été comme le baccalauréat
pour moi
les gens ont des cahiers se mettait
toujours dans les premiers rangs au
cinéma et moi aussi et j'ai rencontré
françois je le connaissais pour l'avoir
lutte j'avais un peu cette idée que
françois truffaut était un grognon inné
meriane
ça mais servait possible et séduire des
filles comme jamais la raconter avec le
fait que j'allais gagner de cinéma
français et
il m'a lu mais comment tu as fait pour
contrer mokhefi levage du mot je prends
vraiment j'ai fait fait un peu comme ça
je vais acheter à la rentrée je suis en
septembre et je me en lâchant je me suis
dit bien ça fait super longtemps que je
n'ai pas lu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la guerre n'a pas été
des astres du tout pour le cinéma
français toute une
génération de deux jeunes gens qui
avaient entre
entre 10 et 15 ans au début de la guerre
se sont formés ou sauvés pour certains
dans les salles de cinéma il ya un
appétit pour tout ce qu'on n'a pas pu
voir qui va se mettre en place autour
d'un système justement pour d'accès au
film qui va être pris en charge par les
ciné-clubs les salles d'avant-premières
il y à un phénomène d'une autre nature
qui est on pourrait dire l'existence
d'un très grand nombre d'organismes qui
vont s'emparer du cinéma comme un moyen
de réunir les gens et de discuter de
réfléchir ensemble ce sont les partis
politiques nées de la résistance et
chivu qui apparaissent à la libération
ce sont les églises ce sont les
associations les groupes d'enseignants
les groupes de médecins les groupes un
peu de tout de toutes les corporations
c'est une époque d'extraordinaire
vitalité associative il faut inventer le
monde d'après je perds la tête devient
fou je suis capable de n'importe quoi
les visages daniels et dans la poitrine
comme une blessure dire qu'on ne va plus
seulement au cinéma pour se distraire va
désormais aussi beaucoup au cinéma pour
en parler pour réfléchir pour discuter à
l'issue des projections elle veut la
paix mais de quelle manière le verrons
n'est pas d'amour et
vichy a créé un organisme pour s'occuper
du cinéma qui à la libération devient le
cnc le centre national du cinéma qui
dépend du ministère de l'industrie et
dont les interventions sont de nature
économique et pas culturelle
vers le printemps des bonnes klaus
otages
les américains exigent un libre accès à
peu près complet des productions
hollywoodiennes aux écrans français à un
moment il y avait des quotas que le
négociateur français léon blum l'ancien
dirigeant du front populaire qui négocie
avec monsieur burns accepte
si je suis convaincu que le résultat
lequel nous venons d'abouti
accroîtra encore la reconnaissance
que le peuple français
doit et porte au peuple américain mais
voilà
l'émail
[Musique]
tout d'un coup il y aura un effet de
rattrapage qui va être extrêmement
intense qui va être aussi très très
excitant pour cette génération qui va
avoir aussi accès à ce qui est nouveau
le cinéma américain
déclenche
soulèvement on pourrait dire du cinéma
français qui va obtenir une diminution
des exigences américaines dans domaine
du cinéma
même moment vous avez des films
soviétiques
commencent à arriver certains films
japonais le néoréalisme italien
cette culture cinéphile elle va
engendrer de la littérature critique au
début ça passe beaucoup par sorte de
bulletin le plus célèbre d'entre ces le
bulletin du ciné club du quartier latin
le ccq elle dirigée par par maurice
scherer alias eric rohmer ce bulletin va
devenir la gazette du cinéma où commence
à écrire godard truffaut on trouve les
premiers articles de rivette
un autre lieu très important la
cinémathèque française création de henri
langlois qui propose des films anciens
des films de patrimoine
et c'est là où vont se retrouver ce
petit groupe autour de rohmer qui va
entraîner dans cet endroit ses jeunes
disciples il n'y a pas vraiment de de
d'unité dans sedan dans tout cela il
manque un petit peu un lien
[Musique]
andré bazin n'est pas quelqu'un qui est
né avec le cinéma comme un comme ceux
qui l'ont suivi par exemple les gens
plus jeunes bazin c'est quelqu'un d'un
autre temps
le régime de vichy s'est vengé sur les
écoles normales parce qu'ils
considéraient que les instituteurs
étaient des gauchistes qui avait amené
la défaite de la france en démoralisant
la france donc son monde s'est écroulé
et puis par un hasard puisque les deux
choses ne sont pas liées il a découvert
le cinéma et la cinéphilie en 1944 andré
bazin a commencé à faire une petite
colonne sur le cinéma dès les tous
premiers numéros du parisien libéré donc
le quotidien de la résistance à la
libération et il intervient dans
beaucoup de ciné club le ciné-club de la
cgt le ciné-club du parti communiste
celui que bazin organiser lui-même
puisqu'il a aussi été dans des usines à
la pause présenter des films avec toute
la fédération travail et culture dont il
était un représentant national mais le
ciné club qu'il a fait c'est avec
cocteau nous on va montrer des films qui
n'ont pas eu le succès qui sont des
grands films ou alors on va montrer des
films qui n'arrive pas à sortir enfin
faire le contraire de ce que faisaient
les autres tout les gens connus dans
paris il fallait qu'ils soient là et
l'idée née avec octo de faire un
festival du film maudit
c'est ce ce petit coeur là autour de
bazin autour d'objectifs 49 qui va
déterminer la naissance des cahiers du
cinéma et donc des contemporains vont se
mettre à écrire un petit peu partout et
se fédérer autour de bazin jean-georges
auriol un critique de cinéma qui met en
place la revue du cinéma qui a une
première version avant guerre et puis
ensuite une seconde version à la fin des
années 40
c'est une revue de prestige sur le
cinéma puisque c'est gaston gallimard
qui décide de la publier
oriol s'adjoint un jeune homme qui est
essentielle ment connu à l'époque comme
étant un résistant
la personne importante je pense c'est
jacques doniol valcroze qui ensuite est
devenu cinéaste et qui a été un très
grand critique qui s'entendait très bien
avec bazin l'événement
créateur de
des cahiers du cinéma est un événement
plutôt triste c'est la disparition
brutale de jean-georges auriol
et dont gallimard las tomber la revue du
cinéma donc doniol valcroze et andré
bazin vont décider tous les deux de
créer une revue de cinéma et ce à un
distributeur de films et qui s'appelle
leonid qu'elle gèle donc un exploitant
quelqu'un qui a une salle très belle
salle au bas des champs elysées qui
s'appelle le broadway qui va décider de
financer cette nouvelle revue
[Musique]
doniol et bazin
forme vraiment un couple qui à mon avis
font la revue 1 c'est vraiment eu
l'image la pensée la technique la
stratégie
doniol et en plus organisée pour la
revue parce que bazin et pris ailleurs
pour la bonne raison qu'il est à temps
complet au parisien libéré qu'il écrit
pour l'écran français qu et qu'ensuite
il va écrire un français observateurs
à la création proprement dit bazin est
en sanatorium et donc jean marie claude
lucas qui est un
grand activiste aussi dans l'histoire du
cinéma français avec doniol va se
retrouve avec deux nuls valcroze
[Musique]
le silence qui a succédé depuis au
travail de la revue de jean-georges
auriol et que sa mort a épaissi a été
troublé par mille et mille questions
venus de tous les pays
ces cahiers volts y répondre
nous reprenons l'exemple patient est
inflexible de notre ami comme lui nous
voulons que le cinéma est un témoin
fidèle de ces efforts les plus hauts et
les plus valables d'où qu'ils viennent
c'est dans ces cahiers la bizarrerie des
cahiers du cinéma sais que bazin est
fondamental pour tous les cahiers jaune
mais néanmoins dans le premier numéro il
n'est pas rédacteur en chef et après dès
le numéro 2 les autres sont tombés sur
le du cac en les rangs l'angle en lui
disant mais il est aussi fondateur que
toi donc faut rajouter le nom de bazin
les cinéastes français sont ravis
d'avoir cette revue à disposition qui
d'une certaine manière défend une le la
vitrine du cinéma français
et c'est quelque chose de très important
pour par exemple rené clément
clouzot cocteau
monsieur jean cocteau à l'honneur de
vous
annoncer avec quel plaisir il a reçu
votre carte une florence sera
primé sa beauté et de chefs-d'oeuvre
sera
plein je sais pas de beauté de
chefs-d'oeuvre je t'embrasse jean 17
juillet 1951 je me suis né le 7
et puis
deuxième photo que j'ai de mon père ma
mère et moi
je suis née en même temps que les
cahiers du cinéma
j'ai cette photo
de mon père que vraiment qui est très
très beau
ensuite une autre photo où je suis avec
mes deux parents
avec la la dauphine qu'ils avaient à
l'époque et qui a servi
énormément aux cahiers du cinéma
ma mère me racontait que en même temps
qu'elle a les livres et les cahiers du
cinéma elle
j'étais là dans mon couffin
elle faisait un petit peu tout là-bas
que
c'était quand même
très studieux malgré le joyeux bazar que
ça pouvait être
bon ce que je me souviens c'est qu'on
rentre par une crainte porte vitrée
voilà et puis ensuite
grande pièce ou une grande pièce oui
quand même surtout très haut de plafond
et le producteur avait eu par
gentillesse donne une pièce gratuitement
donc les bus les cahiers du cinéma
c'était une grande pièce donc il y avait
deux tables rédacteur en chef et la
secrétaire et puis j'avais une autre
petite table pour les mecs qui voulait
réécrire ou corriger un peu leur ticket
puis peu près du coup tout le monde
était debout alors je pense que ma mère
elle devait être souvent ici et elle
tapait la machine là mais j'ai pas de
souvenir de mon père
assis là à
luton 51 doniol et bazin demande à
sherer rohmer d'écrire dans lesquelles
ils donc ce qui fait dans le numéro 3 le
souci entre guillemets pour bazas et et
d'oignons c'est que rohmer ne vient pas
seul
les gens qui rentrent aux cahiers ont à
peine 20 ans
nous même pas et donc on est on est
vraiment dans dans l'irruption
adolescentes mais on très proches de
l'adolescente de ces gens qui vont faire
la revue la plus célèbre de toute
l'histoire des revues de cinéma et c'est
d'ailleurs de cette époque-là de
l'arrivée de ces jeunes turcs aux
cahiers que date le succès des cahiers
c'est eux qui ont fait une revue
polémiques qui l'ont qu'un une prise sur
les lecteurs ce qui de base appelée les
jeunes turcs
pourquoi on disait dur
mais c'était l'emploi qu'ils avaient
appelé comme ça les noms de loi faut pas
l'oublier était d'origine était né à
smyrne en turquie et il avait fui le
génocide arménien les jeunes turcs
s'étaient les jeunes capitaines de
l'armée turque qui ont provoqué le
génocide
enfin ces personnages abject qui
prononce des phrases abject
je connais une poignée d'hommes en
france qui seraient incapables de les
concevoir quelques cinéastes dont la
vision du monde est au moins aussi
valables que celle d'orange et bosc
figurer gens sont autant lara et
delannoy il s'agit de jean renoir robert
bresson jean cocteau jacques becker abel
gance max ophuls jacques tati truffaut
publie un pamphlet
absolument cinglant pour tout le cinéma
établi à son époque et c'est en 1954 ça
s'appelle une certaine tendance du
cinéma français un cinéma
bardé de références culturelles
un cinéma qui cherche à adapter les
grands classiques de la littérature et
vous et qui est pour lui le contraire de
ce qu'il aime au cinéma cinéma il sera
beaucoup plus libre beaucoup plus fondée
sur la mise en scène plutôt que sur le
scénario partira tu partiras
négliger maintenant que le mal est fait
les biens étant vécue par tirage
le seigneur
persuade moi que je ne peux pas
abandonner cet enfant si tu me quittes
je suis perdu perdu pour moi et pour les
autres
perdus pour dieu lui même
j'ai besoin de toi pour les mets
détruis faut s'en prend à des gens
extraordinairement estimé par tout le
monde particulier donc aurenche et bost
les deux scénaristes qui deviennent par
ricochet les cibles principales d'un
texte qui à l'origine n'avait pas du
tout était écrit contre pendant un an
bazin a fait réécrire le texte truffaut
arrondi un peu les angles mais garde sa
fougue et garde son attaque contre le
cinéma français de celui qu'il appelle
le cinéma de qualité en moquant cette
qualité
ce n'est pas le désir de faire scandale
qui m'amène à déprécier un cinéma si
loué par ailleurs je demeure convaincu
que l'existence exagérément prolongée du
réalisme psychologique est la cause de
l'incompréhension du public devant des
oeuvres aussi neuf de conception que le
carrosse d'or casque d'or voir les dames
du bois de boulogne et orphée c'est
comme si aujourd'hui il faisait une
attaque vraiment
dégueulasse en disant que c'est tous des
pédocriminels oui c'est à peu près de
cet ordre là
et cet article que condamnent est tout à
fait bazin et val trône ils l'ont trouvé
très beau très bien écrit et l'ont
publié en réfléchissant longtemps en
faisant un petit texte d'avertissement
on a des lettres
d'indignation littéralement de
désabonnement il y a déjà des réactions
assez vives sur l'article de françois
truffaut et la discussion répondants du
cinéma français paru seulement depuis
deux jours dans nos deux héros devront
pourtant d infléchir
de nouveau sur la sellette
jamais jose maria semble
nous avons d'autres on pense également
accepte que ces jeunes gens écrivent
pour deux raisons c'est c'est la
reconnaissance d'un savoir-faire d'un
savoir d'une érudition sur le cinéma et
la deuxième raison bazin est en quelque
sorte le second père de truffaut un le
parrain truffaut c'est un petit gars de
pigalle qui a volé bon il l'a raconté
ensuite dans les 400 coups à la fameuse
machine à écrire c'est quelque chose
d'absolument réel truffes foie a volé
pour
amortir les dettes de son de son
ciné-club et il a il a été arrêté bazin
va lui trouver un travail pour se porter
garant pour qu'il puisse sortir d'une
dinde un par un bagne d'enfants impasse
point là mais enfin quand même les du
cas d'une éducation surveillée c'est un
jeune homme qui rue dans les brancards
qui a eu beaucoup de problèmes avec
l'armée il s'est engagé volontaire c'est
un déserteur il est en prison un certain
moment en prison militaire et bazin il
le reçoit chez lui et les berges pendant
près d'un an et demi dans une petite
chambre au dessus de l'endroit où il
louait où vivait avec sa famille pour
base un disons je me suis mal exprimé
les sentiments qui me lie à eux sont au
delà de la reconnaissance
pendant les quinze jours que j'ai passés
abri j'ai découvert le bonheur de la vie
familiale une certaine tendance du
cinéma français l'a rendu immédiatement
célèbre et il s'est fait acheter
immédiatement par la revue art et donc
il est passé à l'extrême droite la revue
avait été acheté par un des écrivains du
ca et
il va chercher truffaut qui est la
personne qui va pouvoir faire du
scandale truffaut
entretien même des relations très
trouble 1 avec quelqu'un comme lucien
rebatet par exemple le grand critique
certes mais aussi le collaborateur
antisémite quand doniol valcroze apprend
que truffaut a passé une journée avec
rebatet sur les bateaux mouches à
discuter de cinéma il est tout près de 2
d'arrêter les cahiers c'est quelque
chose est de mettre truffaut à la porte
truffaut a fait vendre pendant des
années la revue art en faisant des
grandes des grands panneaux scandaleux
et puis il a fait travailler tous ses
copains donc ils ont tous écrit dans
hard presque autant d'articles qu'ils
n'ont écrit dans les cahiers du cinéma
quand on lit les cahiers de l'époque on
est parfois arrêtés par des choses qui
sont vraiment mal éteinte
aussi bien au niveau de ceux de voile à
2 c pure provocation de défendre des
films anti communiste par exemple
c'est le paradoxe sont des grands films
certains films de sam elle fut l'air
sont des films militant anticommuniste
et dans le contexte de la chasse aux
sorcières aux états unis ça veut dire
quelque chose
certains textes de 2,2 de rohmer sherer
sur le privilège de la race blanche sont
des choses comme ça qu'on qu'on lit dans
les cahiers 1
en vérité les artistes n'étaient pas
relu un jour chabrol a fait un une série
de trois articles sur le producteur le
figaro le fun le signataire de cet
article a choisi un pseudonyme celui du
personnage principal du roman de norman
mailer le parc aux cerfs ce choix n'est
pas accidentelle nous respecterons
cependant les désirs de notre
correspondant élan dirons pas plus sur
sa personnalité réelle signalons
seulement qu'il a produit et produira
encore
un jour chabrol a dit mais vous ne vous
dites pas beaucoup a lieu pourquoi c'est
pourquoi l'article s'appelle comme ça et
à leur boulot du nom comme ça bon hütte
l'entrevue sur la route et il a dit
parce que c'est le sphinx qui renaît des
cendres de son fils y arts et rives
attali mais c'est pas le seul
fils jeb on l'a fait ah merde tel était
mon état d'esprit
lorsqu'au début de cet hiver je fis sa
connaissance jeune critique fort côté il
m'avait demandé ma collaboration pour un
article j'ai apprécié son talent nos
goûts étaient aussi semblables que le
caractère opposé
ce contraste loin de nous désunir nous
rapprochant j'avais hâte de n'oublier
moi même mais j'ai toujours aimé am
entouré d'amis très différent de moi
[Musique]
et bien c'est certain
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup appris du cinéma
alors bien sûr avec truffaut mais aussi
avec remake et j'étais sans doute celui
là n'est plus aussi d'aller revoir les
films deux fois de suite fois de suite
avec des sous titres sans soutenir
et on allait au cinéma qu'on
l'accompagné hâtives il me parlait comme
ça juste au delà de l'apport de chantier
et puis moi je reprenais un bus de nuit
j'ai vu qu'elle est hors d'eau reliant
l'entrée de l'immeuble on sait a dû
changer
voire
l'un des éléments missiles par tourner
et 1970
[Musique]
jusqu'à la mort oui
il faut les monter enfin je dirais ça
c'était un étage au-dessus d'une
première étape
je crois
oui maintenant avancer tel est le porte
ouverte je sais là
les bureaux québec
satq résume le copain de devenir le
président et nous devrons prêter j'ai
bien été vraiment
de trop celui des tic se sent on allait
voir un film mais ça pouvait aussi se
passer à une époque où il a écrit
pendant trois 3 mois 4 mois
battu par tous les jours dans un journal
et donc ils revenaient pour faire son
truc j'étais très drôle parce que je le
quittais une était dans un tout se
termine comme ça dans un meublé on
parlait un peu du fiv
lyon est brodé un peu ce qu'il allait
dire puis monte est appelée article je
lisais l'article lendemain il merde ce
qu'on fait ce qu'il a pu trouver en
tapant à la machine il a trouvé les
intrus
[Musique]
à la première vision alibaba m'a déçu à
la seconde ennuyé à la troisième
passionné est ravi sans doute le revers
est encore mais je sais bien que passé
victorieusement le cas périlleux du
chiffre 3 to film prend sa place dans
mon musée privé très fermé la politique
des auteurs c'est une expression qui est
complètement lié à l'histoire des
cahiers du cinéma et qui vient de
truffaut et la mise en scène elle est de
jacques becker c'est à dire qu'alibaba
est avec touchez pas au grisbi le film
français le mieux fait de l'année il a
cette formule absurde réussir c'est raté
regardez un tel personnage nous avons
fait appel à la plus grande vedette de
langue arabe aurait si le nom je ne
comprends pas la rade et maintenant ali
ali ben ben ali l'a pas
comme disait rohmer c'est une politique
d'oeuvre complète ses terres qu'il faut
considérer même quelqu'un qui est en
plein travail qui n'a pas fini son
oeuvre on va considérer comme si on
était dans la garde et michard et
comprenait un auteur classique pour son
oeuvre complète quand après mes gars
avait un autre film avec robert
lamoureux archers de lupin était quand
même un peu décevant l'idée ti il était
critique il est embêté vimy non il veut
pas en grande roue vers le coup l'emploi
du mot politique dans la politique des
auteurs je crois qu'il est très
délibérément
voulue pour affirmer que eux ne
s'inscrivent pas dans cette idée là de
la politique d'où l'idée en fait commune
qui est toujours celle que nous avons
d'intervenir dans les débats sur la
société sur l'organisation sur ce qu'on
est contre le capitalisme est ce qu'on
est contre tel parti au pouvoir
oui et c'est pour dire notre politique
vient de l'intérieur du cinéma et notre
politique vient de certaines façons de
mettre en scène contre d'autres façons
de mettre en scène nous ne parlerons que
de ça nous ne parlerons que depuis cette
classe
voici donc comment je vois l'histoire
comment du moins je crois la vue le
metteur en scène
l'a vu le metteur en scène c'est voilà
c'est ça la politique des auteurs s'est
concentrée dans cette phrase là une
fille charmante et quelques peu bêta une
ax terre se console comme elle peut de
l'abandon son fiancé ce qui l'a conduit
tout droit d'une boîte de nuit à la
garçonnière d'un bellâtre de peintre ou
l'alcool aidant points de suspension et
elle se réveille le lendemain chez elle
sa vertu sauf avec le souvenir d'une
lutte la découverte du séducteur
assassiné couvrira de couleur sinistre
la ficelle à cet endroit nous paraît
très grosse si nous ne songeons scabreux
je dis bien de la situation qui va
s'ensuivre
et je saute au paragraphe suivant qui
est un peu plus loin
je ne sais si je me suis bien fait
comprendre ce film comme tant d'autres
films américains finit bien car le
monstre eu lieu la cruauté de la
situation sont telles que celle ci ne
peut autrement aboutir à moins d'une
volonté de pessimisme dont l'art n'a nul
besoin donc on circule avec une aisance
quand même assez impressionnante et une
qualité d'écriture elle n'a rien
spectaculaire n a rien d'ostentatoire
mais elle est quand même assez assez
remarquable entre l'histoire générale du
cinéma et les modes d'esthétique du
cinéma le cas très particulier
l'histoire de ce film le point de vue de
moi je eric rohmer qui s'exprime de
manière tout à fait clair qui est
magnifique en fait dans ce texte qui
tient pas du tout un des textes
inoubliable de d'eric rohmer qui ne
figureraient pas nécessairement dans le
best-of de sort de deux de ses deux de
ses écrits et qui pourtant ouvert comme
ça un peu par hasard
immédiatement
il ya en recèle un très grand monde et
des qualités avec ses ailleurs présents
dans le texte dimension majeure dans
toute la pensée d'eric rohmer de
l'utilisation de l'espace et du rapport
à l'espace pour la mise en scène de
friesland
la plupart ont des pseudos rohmer pour
sherer truffaut en a deux lachenaie
caisson le nom de son vieux copain
d'enfance ou françois de montferrand qui
est le nom de sa mère godard signe hans
lucas jean luc en allemand chabrol signe
jean-yves gouttes ce sont des noms de
code des noms de des noms de résistance
des noms de des nombres de clandestinité
puisque ils vivent cela comme une sorte
de prise d'assaut et puis sinon vous
avez aussi les hitchcock oxia hitchcock
hawks les goûts qui sont des goûts
provocateur de l'époque score adverse
[Musique]
là pendant deux trois ans des petites
notes sur hitchcock disant voilà il se
moque de nous c'est un très bon
technicien mais il fait des films sans
fond et donc il ya une tendance
hitchcockienne très bien illustré par
ces jeunes critiques qui vont se mettre
à défendre les films d'hitchcock ce qui
est à la fois très provocateur et en
même temps aussi très juste parce qu'il
voit chez hitchcock quelque chose que
l'ancien critique ne voit pas c'est à
dire un cinéma éminemment personnel un
cinéma qui passe par la mise en scène un
cinéma qui est celui d'un créateur de
formes
[Musique]
scott n'était pas seulement ce que bazin
disait il disait on a l'impression d'une
casserole qui doit vide alors on a on
était persuadé nous que cette casserole
avec quelque chose dedans et notre
travail et essai était de d'essayer de
le montrer c'était bon pour obliger les
gens à voir les films différemment
j'aimerais avant dans l'extra lisa teurs
il a été attaché de presse et la fox il
était un peu dans le secret qui nous
prévenait un confesse d'un sourcil olala
ça souffre 500 boue et toi quelqu'un en
train de faire des synchros pour la main
au collet cette nuit là on travaille je
travaille
attendez moi de l'autre côté de la cour
dans le bas alors on sort on se dirige
vers le bas on parle on est de le voir
françois c'était la première fois qu'ils
voyaient truffaut qui voyait hitchcock
le il était complètement bouleversé il
on parle et on voit une marche ont
franchi la narration tourner dans un
bassin complète une robe
était complètement frigorifiés on a eu
du mal à sortir à ce que le bassin était
en pente il soit qui est arrivé ont
poussé des cris je crois bien qu'ils
soient qui est arrivé il s'est mis à
rigoler il nous a aidés à nous tirer de
là on a nous a donnés des couvertures on
est allé se réchauffer dans des loges
nous a demandé si on était de la chnouf
parce que on tournait radhika sur la
chnouf en même temps et puis finalement
on a bousillé le magnétophone en
essayant de le faire sécher à la prise
de courant la mise en place de ce
dispositif de l'entretien au long cours
il repose aussi sur l'arrivée d'un
dispositif dans l'appareil nouveaux qui
sont
l'accessibilité des magnétophones à
bandes et leur maniabilité
capacité de les emmener en voyage
ou de pouvoir les installer dans des
endroits un peu n'importe où
[Musique]
ils apprennent la réalisation un peu
comme des peintres 1 vont à rome pour
apprendre leur métier en faisant de la
copie en copiant les grandes oeuvres
classiques
on devient soi même un peintre il ya un
plan dans la maison du docteur edward ou
une belle berman peuvent être meilleur
au directeur de la de la clinique que
c'est lui le coupable la nature de la
clinique il est derrière une table avec
deux bouts
et puis une chanson lvl phare vers la
porte et puis lui dire parce que vous
visiterez pas un pièce in green bien
loin de son vin
il n'a pas le courage de tirer sur elle
le revolver touche dans le plan se
retourne vers l'objectif de la caméra
et il faudra compter qu effectivement on
peut pas avoir la louve pas le point sur
la baie et sur le visage de lieberman
donc qu'est-ce qu'il a fait faire il a
fait une fait faire une main en plâtre
un quart des vols vers quatre fois plus
gros j'ai envie ça n'existait pas un
jeune réalisateur puisque le temps qu'on
ait droit de devenir réalisateur qu'on
ait franchi les étapes imposées par
l'administration et les syndicats on
était plus jeune et que eux ne veulent
pas passer par ce processus là très
bien
et puis munis le problème c'est que on
ne sera pris au sérieux que 40 ans avoue
qu on pas au sérieux d'ailleurs alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avant il faut
cogner il faut faut gagner rien dire
n'importe quoi c'est pas du tout alors
ça pas du tout je le fais une phrase il
ya forcément un lien avec celle qui
précède fait pas la grille il faut que
tu restes avec moi c'est la logique
cartésienne tu m'aimes je t'aime mais si
c'est exprès que je parle comme au
théâtre
voit tout de suite dans un texte de
godard quel cinéaste sera
ses longues phrases ponctuée de point
virgule de rivette on voit très bien un
plan river tiens
là
[Musique]
oui
je vais g
[Musique]
pendant tournage de je ne sais quel film
qu'ils ont fait à l'époque c'est
vraiment tout tout début
d des cahiers du cinéma et on voit mon
père est très jeune
truffaut imiter des rails de coke avec
son cigare
j'étais là
l'actrice principale du premier court
métrage de truffaut
qu'il a complètement renié donc je crois
que personne n'a accès à ce premier film
dans lequel je parais mais voilà mai
bouger un grand rôle paraît-il je devais
avoir deux ans
j'ai commencé à faire des petits films
en 16 mm mais qui ne sont pas montrable
enfin qui d'ailleurs avait tous le un
défaut commun beaucoup de films
d'amateurs ces deux d'être extrêmement
prétentieuse dire de ne même pas avoir
de scénario ce qui à mon avis compte de
la prétention pour un amateur ça donne
même pas raconter une histoire alors ce
qui fait que ceux des films que je n'ose
pas montré qu'ils m'ont quand même ce
probablement appris que mon en tout cas
appris à faire des ellipses parce que
dans le premier il n'y avait que des
porte qui s'ouvrait qui sera fermée
c'est à dire y avait un immense amas de
pellicules gâcher
on s'est rencontré et on s'est promis de
se revoir à paris mais ça ne s'est pas
fait parce que il partait rejoindre
sellini en italie et il m'a dit en
tranches vous téléphone très bien le
téléphone n'ayant jamais sonné
n'est pas non plus appeler les cahiers
et en sortant d'une projection lui avec
ses copains et moi on s'est regroupé à
ce moment là on s'est dit bon baron
serait tel jour
je n'ai vu que les films que françois
choisissait et il a fait mon éducation
univers graphique à ce moment là
ils avaient des habitudes ils allaient
souvent déjeuner dans un petit bar de je
crois que c'était
ce que ces terres ibériques ans était
paru berry
peut-être eu ashington je crois que ça
s'appelait mamys bave il jouait au au
flipper oui
[Musique]
la fin de l'histoire est malheureuse
puisque bazin est morte d'un cancer du
sang à 40 ans qui l'a emporté alors
qu'il était au sommet de son travail il
était en train de refaire son livre sur
orson welles de faire un livre très
important sur renoir et il était en
train de faire un film son premier film
qui n'a jamais fait voilà
je crois que andré bazin qui était le
plus grand critique cinématographique a
également été
presque un père pour moi en tout cas bon
tuteur et je n'aurais sûrement pas fait
cinéma si je ne l'avais pas rencontrée
et je peux dire que mon film se termine
là où ma rencontre avec bazin a eu lieu
toute la presse en émoi ce gosse vient
de faire éclater une bombe
[Musique]
les 400 coups a dit henri georges
clouzot est un film qui m'a positivement
emballé le film le plus sensible que
j'ai vu depuis la guerre quant à
l'appréciation de jean cocteau elle ne
fut pas moins élogieuses je n'ai jamais
été si bouleversée au cinéma
l'ébullition dans le milieu
cinématographique fait partie d'un
période de transformation en profondeur
de l'ensemble de la société française
dans les moeurs dans les comportements
[Musique]
et puis avec la nomination d'andré
malraux comme ministre des affaires
culturelles en 1958 et la mise en place
de nouvelles réglementations de soutien
au cinéma d'auteur et par des
dérogations qui sont accordées très
délibérément par le ministère et par le
cnc à ces jeunes réalisateurs qui ne
remplissent pas les conditions
professionnelles
d'exercice de la réalisation de deux
longs métrages supposons que le cinéma
soit la mer les films sont des bateaux
alors il ya des vieux bateaux des
nouveaux bateaux des jeunes capitaines
des vieux capitaine est alors alors les
vieux les vieux bateau alors je continue
le juge est on sûr suivi une route du
ponant pendant 40 ans la même route et
parmi ces vieux bateau il y en avait qui
cherchait une route nouvelle or selon
les premiers perdu
alors lorsque les nouveaux bateaux sont
arrivés contrairement à ce qu'on pense y
en a beaucoup qui au lieu de suivre la
mi-août ont utilisé la route nouvelle un
exemple très précis c'est l'exemple de
jean cocteau quand il a fait son premier
film librement hors fait il a violé
beaucoup de tabous il a pas d'ampli
clairet en éclaire et éclairé des
visages avec des arcs en gros plan alors
que les arcs serre mais qu'à éclairer
dans les lointains c'est pour ça que la
photo de nicolas hier dans leur fait
extraordinaire voilà il y avait
certaines légendes avec at&t bon de
détruire ces légendes une autre histoire
aussi que souvent quand j'étais
assistant du bosseur via brialy qui
recherchent gérard blain qui piquent tv
il a peur qu'ils créent de francs et où
il y avait un calcul très très loin et
puis avec le câble passait dans la veine
de brialy c'est dans le monde tous et il
brille à lire une lampe torche qui était
survoltée et donc il gérait ce qu'ils
voyaient et or ce qui était drôle
c'était deux cas il disait si tu veux
pour deux voix un peu triché et de temps
en temps fut bouche il inquiet pour
s'éclairer le village
bon c est un film exceptionnel
l'émergence de ces nouveaux films venez
aussi du fait qu'il y avait de nouvelles
pellicules
ultrasensible on n'avait plus besoin des
flots de lumière tout on avait besoin
avant pour tourner
on n'est pas en son direct qu'il n'y
avait pas d'ingénieur du son juste un
accra qui prenait 1 sont témoins mais
ils refaisaient le sont ensuite
du coup des jeunes garçons qui auraient
pas trouver des producteurs pour
produire le film font des films pour les
enfants 4 pour le prix d'un c'était vrai
apparaît comme la grande victoire d'une
gageure tenu par ce jeune est féroce
critique de cinéma qui a osé affronter
le danger de la réciprocité en devenant
à son tour metteur en scène mon père se
produit les fernandel des verneuil et
françois voulait tourner les 400 coups
et mon père lui a dit ils vont très bien
que nous soyons
55 ans l'apport de françois étant son
travail et l'apport de mon père c'était
des led
elle et mon père a produit des 400 coups
il a eu le flair d'acheter quand passent
les cigognes avant le festival de cannes
et il a présenté aussi au même festival
les 400 coups et ses films qui ne lui
ont presque rien coûté on était des plus
grosses affaires de cette année
scénario de françois truffaut
la mort
la petite américaine
le voleurs d'autos
le concerto pour clarinette
la police
supervision de claude chabrol entre 1958
et 1962 il ya environ 200 premiers films
qui vont se tourner ça n'est jamais
arrivé
finalement ce qui était important
c'était pas de savoir si le film
l'airé ou ne plairait pas sera un succès
ne serait pas un succès c'est simplement
le fait de le faire je savais même pas
très bien que j'allais c'était un peu
pour essayer d'éclaircir mes propres
idées et le tournage du film était un
peu une façon d'éclaircir le scénario le
montage une phase en d'éclaircir le
tournage et puis maintenant
effectivement la projection demande
publique a été également une façon
d'éclaircir france entreprise il ya
longtemps que je voulais faire des films
mais il se trouve que j'étais amené
d'abord à aider d'autres des plus jeunes
que moi et que c'est une fois que
avaient pris le départ que vous moi j'ai
l'occasion de faire mon premier film
[Musique]
j'ai eu des rôles parlés dans les films
de mon père
j'avais 8 ans et les jours où je ne
tournais pas c'était les vacances
d'ailleurs c'était mes joueurs préférés
les jours je ne tournais pas parce que
quand je tournais on m'appelait et il
fallait que j'enfile une robe ce que je
détestais quand me vient
je
il y à cette génération de dizaines et
de dizaines voire de centaines de
nouveaux réalisateurs vois d'ici les
recours bien parmi eux il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont la nouvelle vague
telle que nous l'entendons aujourd'hui
c'est à dire les inventeurs les grands
cinéastes des grands artistes qui
donnent naissance à de nouvelles façons
de faire du cinéma y at il une nouvelle
vague non si quelqu'un peut être
considéré comme le père spirituel d'une
vague c'est être andré bazin qui est
mort hélas et qui était vraiment le
maître de cette nouvelle école sa pensée
et théorie la question intéressante
c'est de savoir si il y à une relation
directe entre la critique et le et la
réalisation et si bazin était devenu un
cinéaste est ce qu'il aurait été un
nouveau signer un autre cinéaste de la
nouvelle vague
c'est vraiment très curieux moi je pense
que non je ne pense pas que ce soit une
école je pense que tout ça est de
l'ordre du hasard historique truffaut
chabrol n'écrira n'écriront plus de
textes critiques une fois qu'ils sont
devenus des cinéastes et en même temps
il reste chacun soit par leur
attachement aux cahiers soit par la
façon dont ils font du cinéma des
critiques en puissance
des metteurs en scène ou des futurs
metteurs en scène avait appris le
français pour lire les cahiers du cinéma
milos forman va expliquer ça quand il
est arrivé en france après les
événements de prague et pour partir
après aux états unis il parlait français
il parlait pas anglais à l'époque
résultat des courses schlöndorff qui
était l'assistant qui a fait ses études
en france par ailleurs et qui était
l'assistant de louis malle immédiatement
se dit mais moi je vais retourner en
allemagne et je vais faire la même chose
il va créer fine verlhac des rottes
veine avec son ami alexander plueger
c'est vrai qu'ils vont regrouper des
metteurs en scène qui vont s'atteler
quand même werner schroeter
vilander ita ils vont tout chambouler
la même chose va se passer au chili et
du cinéma nouveau c'est le même principe
[Musique]
en italie ce sera bernardo bertolucci et
marco bellocchio qui euro passaient leur
temps à la cinémathèque française
[Musique]
donc finalement l'âme ce l'étincelle
c'est la cinémathèque française les
cahiers du cinéma
[Musique]
les cahiers vont accompagner et souvent
stimuler l'extension
de la nouvelle vague au monde entier
donc il ya vraiment ce mouvement et qui
continue ensuite dans les années 80 90
avec l'apparition d'une nouvelle
cinéphilie avec le travail
de la rédaction vers l'asie il ya
vraiment une réflexion permanente et une
mutation de la revue qui s'adapte à la
question du temps à 21 22 ans je voulais
faire des films déjà en pratiquant la
critique de cinéma j'ai pu mettre le
doigt on va arriver à formuler dans
certains films une utilisation de la
musique que je trouvais
antipathique enfin qui pour moi devait
devait faire réfléchir et et
je voulais ne pas être otage d'une
certaine utilisation de la musique comme
ton de spectateurs leçons et apprendre à
ne pas être otage c'est un travail en
soi et c'est un travail qui passe pour
moi par l'écriture par la réflexion
il était respecté dans le monde entier
la nouvelle vague c'était lui jean luc
godard
monsieur et madame nous ont tué une
fille et l'on revienne à rien marionnaud
oui mon amour
marions-nous le film que j'ai faits n'a
rien n'à ne s'inscrit absolument pas
dans la nouvelle vague c'est à dire que
il utilise des motifs il utilise des
manières de faire on les détournant les
extrapolant besoin d'eau dont faisaient
parfois presque des copier-coller met au
service du d'un film qui est ultra
classique c'est à dire un film qui met
en scène des personnages quand je vois
les réactions
ont créé que ça a provoqué c'est vrai
que toutes les discussions mais mal à
l'aise en fait c'est à dire parce qu'en
vrai on n'est pas du tout dans la même
chapelle et donc
c'est c'est compliqué quand vous êtes
quand vous jouez au barça de bien bons
joueurs un copain qui aurait elle
n est pas du tout génial cette allégorie
mais non mais je veux dire
quand vous êtes à montaigu de dire
bonjour qui a pu laisser ainsi mieux moi
je pense que l'esprit de la nouvelle
vague
il a perduré dans le cinéma français le
problème de cet esprit c'est qu'il est
devenu en fait majoritaire c'est ça le
problème c'est à dire que quelque chose
qui était provocateur est minoritaire en
1900 à la fin des années 50 est devenue
la norme du cinéma la manière de faire
les films raconter des histoires
personnelles
françois a demandé par testament que je
gère les films du carrosse après sa
disparition cette histoire pourrait
s'intituler ni avec toi ni sans toi
ce que tu veux parce que en fait c'était
l'unique bien qu'il laissait à ses
filles
pour un jeune critique d'aujourd'hui
retrouver quelque chose qui serait de
l'ordre du combat des cahiers du cinéma
du milieu des années 50 ça ça a du sens
il me semble et
etc ça a du sens parce que c'est pas
évident aussi quoique la particularité
des cahiers c'est que
on considère la critique dans sa plus
haute acception en fait la critique est
considérée comme une création et pas
comme un geste satellite de l'oeuvre qui
serait elle la création
comment vous terminez un journal non
mais la phrase que vous allez dire en
soirée et qui serait cadre et comme
d'habitude pour dire ça non normalement
normalement sur la une je pense en
groupe langue voilà bon c'est ça vous a
fait un gros plan moi je pense qu'il
faudrait le cadre est comme ça
enlever une lumière par exemple ici est
simplement moi ce pas mal dit l'europe
on arrive au revoir et ya 2 m eur
prévalant au lait l'apli davout rigoler
vous n'êtes pas sérieux vous pensez pas
vous allez les revoir demain
[Musique]